we are sad to another Eurogroup meeting
we have important decisions on the table
we need to pin down details on the big
very important ones of course I'm
referring especially to those related
with governments and financing a big
this is a very important instrument for
the eurozone and we need to take some
conclusions today on this on this file
but there are other issues on the menu
as well
we have Portugal we passed the economic
situation of Portugal based on the post
program evaluation of the institution's
of course we are looking forward to good
news from Portugal given the economic
performance of the country in recent
semesters and year so one of the topics
in the agenda as well and we also look
at the ECB top jobs and finally we will
look at the economic situation of the of
the eurozone especially on this debate
between the physical science and
economic conditions to continue the
trajectory of growth in the Sun is very
important instruments available for that